all right it was really really hard to
stop and record this review and not just
business through to the next episode
[Music]
broadchurch series 1 episode 7 yeah this
really is holding the momentum that was
built up in episode 6 if the last
episode can stick the landing this'll
this will end up having a really really
strong finish which is what a mystery
needs I mean any good mystery it needs a
it needs a solid setup but it has to
nail the ending because if we get to the
answer to the mystery if you've either
lost interest along the way or they get
you know to the reveal you go no I don't
buy that then you know it's screwed so
hopefully that won't happen but that's
that's me worried about what next
episode because pretty much as soon as I
finish recording this and popping that
in but yeah this was this was good this
is I love the interrogations of Susan
and Nigel the the way that plays out and
watching watching Miller really knuckle
down I I was almost a little bit annoyed
that Tennant's character came back from
the hospital so quickly because I was
really enjoying watching her kind of
step up and she doesn't get to do that
for very long but she does still get to
sort of embody this I don't want to say
new strength I think she's always had it
but new level of determination that she
has you know in an interrogating Susan
and the back story for Susan was
something that on paper I think hearing
it normally would have made me roll my
eyes and go that's really unnecessary
that's really sleazy we don't need that
for some reason it actually works here I
think a lot of it might come down to the
performance there's something very
compelling very conflicted
about her performance and there's
something also very conflicted about
Miller and her the way she reacts and
responds to the story that she gets told
by Susan and suddenly then now the
dynamic between her and Nigel makes
total sense I was really wondering how
the heck they're gonna justify what was
going on there because I figured it I
figured it was yeah maybe not a full-on
red herring but you know it wasn't just
gonna like end up being them like but
there was something going on there but
that's that background plays really well
and like I said it's the sort of thing
that normally I would not like so I'm
honestly having a hard time figuring out
precisely why I think it's just
something about the pacing and the the
way it unfolds the fact that they just
walk in on Susan's face as she's talking
about this so they're not cutting to
like a slow-motion hazy flashback like
if that had happened it probably would
have lost me and I would have hated it
but it didn't it just it makes it less
about the events of what happened and
more about her experience because it
just locks in on her it's a bit in that
way like quints monologue from Jaws
where because you just go in on the
person telling the story the important
information is actually not the story
that they're telling it's what it says
about them and what the way that they
tell it says so that that was really
well done and seeing Nigel you know get
that information and we we have a we
have a montage with no words but we see
him breaking out like I can boom man I
can't I can't even imagine I do worry
that that things are getting slightly
oversimplified and in in terms of
pointing towards you know well he's just
like his father
certainly Susan believes that I don't
know if the audience is expected to
believe that Nigel's not a good guy it
was nice to realize he didn't kill the
dog so yay
I'm not he doesn't get points for
you don't get points for me because you
didn't kill a dog no no that's oh look
you didn't slaughter an animal have a
cookie no but that was a relief for me
because that again would come off as
cheap and sleazy and uh and unnecessary
so all that has working really well the
the background on I don't know why I
can't remember David Tennant's
character's name I don't know but the
the background on David Tennant in terms
of his health is interesting and tracks
it makes a certain amount of sense I
don't know how much the health thing
actually adds to the story at this point
especially considering it didn't take
him out of commission for Miller to take
over for any real significant amount of
time that said it was interesting seeing
him turn to the supposed psychic again
and the cop the guy still just doing
cold readings you can tell because he'll
he'll float something and see that he
gets the reactions and zooming those I'm
right aren't I and and so I'm hoping
that he is just gonna remain what he is
what he appears to me to be to be just a
guy he does cold readings he takes
advantage he's you know this is not real
and I don't want it to even hint that it
might be you know you don't have to
flat-out prove him a charlatan but don't
don't point to it being real because
right now it all tracks as as a standard
parlor trick kind of stuff but they also
made it believable as to why David
Tennant would have gone to him at this
point because he is running out of time
and he is desperate for these answers
and him giving his background in terms
of what happened at San Brooke because
which is something that it's been
alluded to since episode one we've had
this getting alluded to and that that
was interesting again in what it told us
about him not entirely because of his
actions in the story but because of you
know his reluctance to tell
and realizing why he didn't want to tell
this story and the guy man this guy's
got a martyr complex yeah you know in
terms of taking that burden on himself
so that his kid wouldn't think you love
of his now ex-wife and it's yet at the
same time you know I'm sure in some ways
he's he takes it as a punishment onto
himself and it all tracks really
interestingly and I wanna I want to find
out I want the answers and and I said
the the the momentum and the pacing of
all this has is just it was so hard to
break away so yeah that's this episode
I'm gonna go watch the last one now and
then you get to watch that review
tomorrow so episode 7 broadchurch series
1 have you seen it what you think about
it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it support me on patreon
follow me on twitter yada yada links for
other stuff is down in the description
so until next time this council's joked
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]